there are so many people that are better
cooks than I am I think my strength is
being able to be personable with people
and like make sure that they like feel
really nourished and happy there's big
ole beautiful trees that were here
before me they'll be here after me the
farm always keeps me humble
[Music]
these are stamen Winesap apple trees
i've got about 70 trees here i do the
pruning by myself takes me about 5 to 8
hours per tree on an average day when
I'm cooking for a client I'll usually
start at the farmers market I try to
find the most unusual produce and I make
something I've never made before with it
so that's also on the list for today so
where everybody funnels through here
when they're done with their you pick
with my meatballs whatever sauce I put
on I also sell that sauce
hi what is this this is the old for
Chinese quoi oh thank you Oh interesting
it is tempura and sometimes I don't
necessarily have all those ingredients
at home but we could get them I did some
searching online for some recipes that
look legit so we're just gonna grab a
few items oh yeah there's already a line
out there as soon as we open up the gate
if you guys can help me get the signs
out there
I feel so weirdly prepared are we ready
to pick some apples today if you're
wanting to pick apples we're harvesting
our stamen Winesap apples today where
are you visiting from okay not too far
damn this mint smells so good this is a
combination of ingredients for salads
for a client lunches to take to work and
then also ingredients for my nosh with
Tasha Instagram I actually started
cooking pretty late in life I wanted to
be an actor like everybody else in their
mother I didn't like the food at school
I was like I kind of want to find a way
to merge performing and food I'm 58 I
was in my early 30s we were just driving
by and I just fell in love with the land
itself we moved here and then you know I
make $3,000 for a whole year's labor so
that's when we decided well we were
going to try and do you pick on the farm
I got a job assisting teaching cooking
classes and then it just sort of like
snowball and private chef work and doing
not Latasha for the most part I've been
really lucky
I'm obsessed with the salad spinner in
the video that I just put out where I
made a frittata it was a video sponsored
by hawk so I'm wearing a shirt the last
of the meatballs today we're gonna cook
40 pounds of Meatballs I started out
just going to Trader Joe's getting the
little meatballs there and then it got
to where I had come in and wipe out the
whole refrigerator supply area and Vince
when I realize like I've grown past the
turn to do this thing these are frozen
solid there are definitely certain laws
about the amount that you can cook at
home for it to be legal until recently
it was like $60,000 if I had all the
money in the world this is where I live
I love this like craggly area between
the Palisades in Santa Monica
okay so 5:45 told somebody 11:30 please
out of 20 let me get you a little bag
there for your goodies thank you very
much you guys have a great day for
little tiny farms like me you have to
diversify because I can work my best and
a hailstorm can come and wipe out my
crop in one day we've shot movies here
we've had print ads I've done some
wedding so it took some heat for that so
I stopped doing that right right my
neighbor complained and that's how the
first you know county permitting issues
came about when code enforcement came
out they're like I can't believe
somebody's complaining about this
beautiful farm but if you're a powerful
person up here what you complain about
will be taken care of sure when do you
need it when I do recipe testing for
branded content a little bit like ghost
writing if you will what I'm working on
right now is a spicy fried chicken that
you can tuck inside of a bubble waffle
the first thing I do is you know make
them a bunch of times and then I'll just
send them guideline photos so this will
take me about three hours and I bill for
this type of work at 100
an hour yesterday we grossed about 3,800
when we're busy they're more like $8,000
days you might think that $8,000 sounds
like a lot for a day but there's gonna
be months when there's no income but the
work still continues here the next nost
with Tosh episode that I have coming out
is tied pumpkin soup so this already
this first piece has to go because it's
just too long wooden like someone else
is paying you to do a recipe you have to
follow with very specific guidelines and
it has to be like really professional
and this just feels so like this is just
me hanging out who's ready to pick some
apples anyway before I send you on your
way I'm gonna give you a couple of tips
when you're picking one Apple you might
have a few more come down okay I've
never been motivated by money which
makes me a terrible business woman when
I do preschool tours I top out at 48
kids my neighbors might bring in six
different schools at one time in buses
there's one predominant family and they
have almost a total monopoly they
probably make more money than me I would
imagine that they're not picking up
apples every morning like I am yes can I
make a lot of money really fast I think
that's what some of my competition does
and I've just always taken the exact
opposite approach looking pretty good on
that tractor all right
I don't know how to know how old an oppo
is oh cool wow it really does look like
a cross between a squash and a cucumber
with the seeds in the center it has a
little bit of a like a slimy mountain
yam texture it's not my favorite thing
about raisins
now we're at a perfect deep-fry these
look like a stupid American datum more
better is better
[Music]
we sold a lot of the other one yeah
pretty much every day I'm open I have
people come in kind of stricken you know
why is there a first the hillside I had
intended to do it longer but I'm also
one that believes that you got to listen
to what the universe is telling you I
wonder if I'll ever feel comfortable
with where I'm at I feel like that's
sort of like I know a lot of people who
are way way way more successful than me
that I think also have this same like
internal desire to continue like growing
and doing better I can comfortably
afford my life and do it in a flexible
way but do I feel like I'm where I want
to be when my neighbors are complaining
to the county when the county is giving
me cease and desist orders it takes the
joy away the problem with doing what you
love you should put your heart and soul
into it you know so which is what people
love about it but you know it makes it
hard when you what do you might need to
leave
my kids are like mom you work so hard
get out and go do something else maybe
it's just time I try to make a lot of
time for friends and to like be a good
neighbor
like brighten people's days in small
ways I don't know I don't know how much
your happiness should be connected to
your success like if that's just an
unwinnable metric I don't know but if
that was all that I connected my
happiness to like then I wouldn't be
happy mother nature is pretty amazing
you know when you stand next to a tree
like this
I mean imagine all the history that's
occurred in a hundred years that's still
here and it's still standing and it's
still producing beautiful apples
[Music]